partout de la machinerie et des
échafaudages l'hôpital de saint-jérôme
ressemble à un malade aux soins
intensifs et son urgence vie crise après
crise depuis le début de la pandémie les
cancéreux avec les dialysés avec les
malades pulmonaires chroniques tout le
monde en un an et quelques coqs
copenhague ouais plusieurs civières sont
à moins de 30 cm l'une de l'autre
difficile d'isoler les patients qui ont
des symptômes de co vide à l'heure
actuelle on est des patients show
mélangé au froid dans à peu près toutes
les sections de l'urgence la situation
se serait améliorée depuis quelques
jours mais le problème de fond
demain vu qu'il y avait trop de patients
à l'urgence on essayait de réouvrir les
champs multiples on erévan les champs
multiples on a créé des éclosions un
grave problème reconnu par la directrice
du sis des laurentides lors d'une
conférence avec des médecins
le 11 novembre l'hôpital avait été
touché à la première vague et de
nouvelles éclosions émerge depuis
novembre huit unités ont été frappées
dans l'oncologie
depuis le début de la pandémie 277
patients ont attrapé la coved à
l'intérieur de l'hôpital
76 d'entre eux sont morts après avoir
été infectés un chiffre très élevé selon
plusieurs experts consultés par radio
canada
oui ce sont pas des chiffres qui sont
ici c'est pas des chiffres qu'on qu'on
est content de voir non plus le risque
d'infection est important assez pour que
des médecins conseillent à leurs
patients de partir le plus vite possible
après une opération
c'est pour ça que je les conseille de
quitter et je vous dirais qu'avec
l'apport de la population de contracter
l'aco vide les patients sont je dirais
bien réceptif le vieil hôpital est
simplement trop petit pour une
population qui a doublé depuis 40 ans
son hôpital qui ont reçu de 400 à lille
tout toute mission confondues et c'est
insuffisant pour répondre aux besoins de
la population des laurentides
le remède à court terme est cette
structure temporaire on y hébergera dès
janvier 57 patients en convalescence
pour le maire de saint-jérôme c'est un
symbole des retards dans la
reconstruction
comment se fait-il qu'on a fait une
annonce importante en 2019 et que
presque deux ans plus tard vous n'auriez
sur l'état des travaux l'état des
avancements la planification pourtant le
premier ministre s'est lui même étonné
des délais ça pas de bon sens qu'on dit
ça va prendre encore trois quatre ans va
commencer les travaux à l'hôpital de
saint jérôme
la reconstruction a été repoussée de
2027 à 2029
les soignants de saint-jérôme crie à
l'est est ce que le fait qu'on ait des
éclosions à tour de bras qui ont créé
des morts ça suffit pas pour se re effet
se réveiller pétille hockey à cet
endroit là dans les laurentides ont
besoin d aide ici david gêne-t-il et
radio canada montréal